messieurs bonsoir merci de répondre à
nos questions je cite les échéances
démocratiques seront maintenus c'est ce
qu'avait dit emmanuel macron il ya deux
semaines mais c'était avant que l'on
voit les deux cent mille trois cent
trente mille ce soir 400 milles c'était
lundi selon elle des nouveaux calculs
cas donc journalier de coheed est ce que
les français votre ont-ils bien les 10
et 24 avril prochain selon vous franck
seules 81 greffes commence avec vous
il a écouté je dois vous dire que je
pense qu'ils n'auront pas d'autre choix
quoi qu'on en pense
parce que la constitution dispose que le
mandat du président de la république
s'achève le 13 mai 2022 et donc si l'on
reporte le vote eh bien nous aurons une
carence à l'elysée alors un intérêt qui
me
organisée au profit du président du
sénat mais la constitution ne prévoit
absolument rien pour une élection qui
serait décalé est organisé après la fin
du mandat du président de la république
donc je pense que il faut que ce scrutin
ait lieu c'est une question vraiment
alors là de sécurité constitutionnel
pour notre pays on peut regretter que le
souhait du modem notamment de voir se
développer par exemple le vote
électronique n'est pas été où le vote
par correspondance n'est pas été
entendus au cours du mandat
évidemment ce sera sans doute une
élection difficile mais c'est une
élection impératif parce que nous
n'avons pas le choix elle ne peut pas
constitutionnellement être reporté
jacques muller a votre avis il
est vrai que à la date d'aujourd'hui je
pense que l'élection aura lieu alors je
suis assez d'accord avec mon collègue du
modem
ce n'est pas je dirais une politique
constante chez moi mais il y a des
possibilités effectivement aussi de
repousser légèrement les élections à la
condition c'est la lente et
l'avant dernier alinéa de l'article 7
qui dit que le conseil constitutionnel
peut à ce moment-là prendre des
décisions de report et que les élections
doit par lieu obligatoirement dans un
délai de trente cinq jours après la
décision du conseil constitutionnel
donc on voit bien que on est coincé par
la constitution enfin coincé la
constitution donne des dispositions la
loi organique les confirme et je pense
que c'est jouable cela étant il va
falloir prendre des mesures extra
crâniennes pour assurer la sécurité
premièrement des assesseurs des
présidents des bureaux de vote et de nos
concitoyens qui viennent voter je pense
effectivement que la question du vote
électronique va se poser tôt ou tard
parce que aujourd'hui tous les
gouvernements ont fait marche arrière
pour des raisons de sécurité
condé raison aussi de civisme c'est à
dire que l'acte de vote n'est pas
quelque chose que l'on fait de chez soi
dans son fauteuil mais est un acte on se
rend dans un lieu particulier que sont
les bureaux de vote et aujourd'hui on
peut penser qu'en fonction de ses
nécessité sanitaire il eût fallu sans
doute envisager le vote électronique
malheureusement c'est une question très
sensible à la môle dalit et les
modalités de vote ces questions qui va
être abordée très certainement mardi
autour de jean castex olivier ferrand et
gérald darmanin à quoi est-ce qu'il faut
s'attendre sur cette question selon vous
un vote à distance ou venez de le dire
comme ce qui s'est fait par exemple aux
etats-unis c'est quand même envisageable
même si ça a été écartée france 4,9
il faudrait
une modification législative
alors je par exemple je sais que dans la
niche parlementaire du modem patrick
mignola présidente groupe a placé la
question du vote par procuration du vote
par correspondance pardon mais on n'aura
pas le temps de le voter les délais sont
trop courts
donc il faudra faire avec les textes
actuels si vous voulez la la
constitution vraiment nous protège enfin
je pense que on doit la respecter mais
c'est aussi la guerre pointe de nos
libertés qu'on ne peut pas faire
n'importe quoi on ne peut pas virer dans
un régime d'exception quand il s'agit
d'un scrutin présidentiel là c'est
vraiment le roi des scrutins donc je
pense qu'il faut tant pis il faudra
prendre toutes les mesures sanitaires il
faudra essayer de mobiliser les
électeurs il faudra essayer de les
motiver les protéger en même temps mais
on ne peut pas sortir des clous
constitutionnel et on n'aura pas le
temps de voter de nouveaux textes que
c'est évident
jacques milliards
enfin
il lui fallu envisager ça bien avant et
surtout et peut-être tester ça avec des
élections moins
importante si l'on peut dire si on peut
employer ce mot mais maintenant je crois
que les dés sont jetés et ils fabre art
il va lui falloir voter dans les
conditions fixées par l'article 7 de la
constitution qui donne une petite marge
de manoeuvre il faut pas se tromper
relisez géré amis
l'avant dernier alinéa de l'article 7 il
pourrait y avoir un report léger mais à
partir du moment où le conseil
constitutionnel
dira voilà ma décision l'élection
présidentielle doit avoir lieu dans les
35 jours donc on est toujours dans les
mêmes délais soit 20 soit 35 jours et
donc il va falloir faire avec et je vois
mal comment on ne puissent pas voter
aujourd'hui dans des conditions qui sont
des conditions classiques mais qui
apporte une certaine sérénité également
aussi à l'élection présidentielle se
déplacer dans un bureau de vote
déposer son bulletin
vérifier son identité
sont là des conditions de sincérité du
scrutin qui sont importantes et que nous
devons respecter j'ose espérer que d'ici
effectivement les dates de 10 avril et
du 24 avril je vais rédiger les dates
sur mon petit papier on a on a des
meilleures conditions sanitaires mais ça
c'est à dieu vat personnes séoul mais si
on se souvient quand même un des
municipales en 2020 ça va engendrer de
nombre de nombreux cas de co vide est ce
qu'on peut se retrouver dans une même
situation
on peut on peut moi même j'en ai je
dirais nous avons fait le premier tour
en masse et nous avons fait le deuxième
tour au mois de juin et je peux vous
dire que pour le maire que j'étais le
maire sortant ce n'était pas si facile
parce qu'il fallait gérer la ville ne
pas se tromper de ne pas utiliser la
ville comme un instrument électoral
choses que bien évidemment je n'ai pas
fait et donc c'est pas si évident que ça
ce sont des conditions difficiles à nous
républicain de les respecter on sera 4 9
oui mais tout à fait je suis tout à fait
d'accord et vous savez honnêtement
reporté de quelques jours de quelques
semaines n'arrangerait rien parce que
malheureusement on n'a pas de
prévisibilité quant à la pandémie donc
si vous voulez c'est vraiment une seule
cartouche conquirent est qu'on pourrait
se tirer dans le pied en réalité en
simple la pandémie la responsabilité
elle sera portée
oui mais vous avez
aujourd'hui contrairement à ce qui s'est
produit quand nous tenions des bureaux
de vote notamment au premier tour
nous avons des protections aujourd'hui
tout le monde va au magasin que monde à
faire ses courses où tout le monde alors
on cite toujours les transports en
commun quand 35 heures encore ces
dernières 24 heures même si on a les
protections les chiffres sont là oui
mais écoutez oui certes
il ya le vaccin monsieur le maire a
raison et par ailleurs écouté la
l'élection présidentielle c'est vraiment
trop important nous sommes une
démocratie nous souhaitons le rester il
faut voter c'est impératif alors
voteront ce qu'ils pourront ce qu'ils
voudront à nous de les inciter mais on
ne peut pas traiter avec tout le respect
que j'ai pour les mères j'étais moi même
candidat une municipale mais si vous
voulez c'est quand même moins dramatique
de reporter le second tour d'une
municipale que de reporter l'élection
présidentielle on ne peut pas se
permettre de reporter une élection
présidentielle ça n'est pas possible
lorsqu'il sera abordé également mardi
c'est la question peut-être des meetings
également l'exécutif qui a exclu
d'imposer toute restriction aux meetings
politiques donc la responsabilité à les
renvoyer aux organisateurs quelles
conséquences jacques myard
savez je veux dire une chose l'élection
présidentielle c'est bien les meetings
j'en ai fait j'en est co-organisé on se
retrouve on se moquera tulle viennent
dans les mythiques ceux qui sont déjà
convaincus et donc en réalité ce qui se
passe c'est que l'élection
présidentielle c'est une élection qui va
se passer à la télévision dans les
médias dans la radio et croyez moi c'est
beaucoup plus efficace pour porter son
programme les son projet quand il existe
donc le programme et le projet existe
que des meetings dans lesquelles chacun
va se retrouver parce que qu il y va et
qu'il est convaincu par avance
france à 80 votre avis sur sur les
meetings pour terminer c'est la dernière
question après c'est la fin de
décryptage de ce débat je pense que le
gouvernement a raison de laisser
possible ce temps jauge toujours pour
des raisons de libertés
constitutionnelles et de laisser les
candidats face à leurs responsabilités
c'est bien certain c'est démocratique
mais jacques myard a raison honnêtement
à part le plaisir de nous retrouver nini
qu'ils ne servent qu effectivement a
crié en choeur que nous allons gagner
même quand on finit à 2% ce qui nous
arrivera pas bien évidemment mais ce qui
a pu nous arriver par le
non pas 2 % pas de course
merci merci franz quatreboeufs d'avoir
répondu à une question vous êtes délégué
départemental du modem dans le nord
merci également à vos jacques muller
maire les républicains en deux maisons
laffitte en région parisienne